ahorita y entendimos tres cosas de la
situación de grecia número uno que la
austeridad sería muy difícil porque es
políticamente impopular y además podría
llevar a grecia a una recesión más grave
también entendimos número dos que el
incumplimiento de deuda no es una opción
y finalmente entendimos que tendría que
hacer una grecia independiente
monetariamente para salir de esta
situación con estas tres ideas podemos
platicar de una opción para grecia en su
situación actual
pensando en que no va a obtener ayuda de
ningún otro miembro de la unión europea
en vídeos futuros vamos a platicar
porque algunos miembros de la unión
europea en realidad quieren evitar hacer
lo que ahorita te voy a contar pero
bueno en un mundo ideal grecia tendría
su propia moneda y podría imprimir
dinero para poder aprovechar la
inflación y deshacerse de sus deudas
también si tuviera su propia moneda y
esto que te voy a contar no está tan
padre porque haría que se perdiera mucha
confianza de inversión pero incluso en
este caso el incumplimiento de deudas
sería una opción porque como grecia
tiene acceso a su propia moneda podría
seguir imprimiendo dinero para prestarle
al gobierno y con eso el gobierno puede
pagar sus obligaciones nominales que
poco
con la inflación en términos reales van
disminuyendo bueno entonces lo que
grecia tendría que hacer sin ningún otro
miembro de la unión europea lo quisiera
ayudar si no hubiera un rescate
financiero básicamente sería que grecia
tendría que abandonar el euro grecia
abandona el euro
abandona abandona el euro y la mecánica
para realizar esto bueno déjame primero
decir que el euro se pasa al drug o sea
que su moneda su nueva moneda sería una
nueva forma del track está la forma en
la cual esto sucedería mecánicamente
vaya el procedimiento pues sería número
uno declarar vacaciones bancarias esto
suena bien padre verdad hubo vacaciones
pero una vacación bancaria esencialmente
sería que todos los bancos van a cerrar
por un cierto periodo de tiempo y en ese
periodo de tiempo va a haber una
transición a la nueva moneda o sea al
dracma entonces entrando en las
vacaciones bancarias teníamos el euro
como moneda es decir todas las personas
tenían depósitos y ahorros en euro en
los bancos pero después de las
vacaciones bancarias ahora el dracma va
a ser la nueva moneda
cuentas bancarias quedan en dragma y
después el gobierno va a tener que
establecer cierto tipo de cambio un
cierto tipo de cambio entre el euro y el
dracma por ejemplo va a decir que cada
euro que cada euro cada euro que tú
tengas sería igual ao se convertiría
igual a un dracma pero esto va a ser muy
arbitrario o sea después el mercado de
divisas va a tener que determinar a
través de la ley de la oferta y la
demanda y así el verdadero tipo de
cambio bueno entonces todo el mundo
compra y venden dragma ahora y además el
gobierno ya tendría sus obligaciones en
dracmas esto pues básicamente va a hacer
caer en incumplimiento de deuda porque
ve si así le dicen a sus prestamistas lo
siguiente a sus prestamistas que ya no
les debe en cuanto era a ver vamos acá
arriba para ver el numerito este de acá
es 350 mil millones de euros bueno
supongamos que son 400 mil millones
porque ya estamos más cerca de 2012
entonces si les dicen a sus prestamistas
que ya no les deben 400.000 millones de
euros sino que ahora les dicen les dicen
digamos que les deben 400 mil millones
de 'drag más
ahora les van a decir que les deben eso
o no se les podrían decir 600 mil
millones de drama o lo que sea les digan
lo que les digan aunque les dieran un
trillón de drag man de todas formas
vamos a caer en incumplimiento de deuda
porque estos prestamistas pues no habían
acordado eso verdad lo que ellos
esperaban era cuatrocientos mil millones
pero de euros entonces si no les damos
euros y les damos digamos fresas o si le
damos plátanos o dragma pues eso de
todas formas sería un incumplimiento de
deuda bueno lo pongo aquí incumplimiento
de deuda de deuda pero la ventaja es que
ahora el pueblo griego puede seguir con
sus vidas bueno si va a haber algunas
dificultades y algunas cosas locas que
van a pasar de las cuales ahorita vamos
a platicar sin embargo por el momento el
gobierno va a poder imprimir su propio
dinero usar eso para comprar deuda
gubernamental y ya a partir de ahí pagar
sus obligaciones las cuales poco a poco
con la inflación van a ir disminuyendo
mira imaginemos la situación la
situación en la cual ahorita digamos que
el producto interno bruto real vamos a
acá arriba a ver cuánto dice el producto
interno bruto real
aquí nomás tenemos el crecimiento del
producto interno bruto real bueno vamos
a inventar en su número supongamos que
el producto interno bruto real es de 100
mil millones 100 mil millones bueno o
sea lo equivalente a 100 mil millones
de drácula entonces pues si el gobierno
sigue imprimiendo dragma pero la
economía se mantiene igual entonces si
vamos a pensar que está con la misma
productividad pero bueno supongamos que
en el transcurso de 10 años este
producto interno bruto real no cambia
debido a la impresión de dinero la
vibración va a aumentar y digamos que el
producto interno bruto pasa de 500 mil
en término nominal vale bueno esto que
nos dice en términos de los precios y de
la inflación pues la inflación ahora va
a ser de 5 verdad tenemos la misma
cantidad de bienes y servicios pero
debido a la impresión de dinero ahora
todo cuesta 5 veces más pero qué sucede
con la deuda bueno pues el dinero para
pagar los impuestos crecen con la
inflación porque son un porcentaje del
producto interno bruto sin embargo las
obligaciones permanecen igual permanecen
con su valor nominal en términos reales
se convierten en un quinto de lo que
valían y de repente se vuelven pagables
como te dije antes de esto de aquí no es
fácil de hacer y es doloroso después
tenemos que practicar un poco más acerca
de las repercusiones que esto tiene para
la unión europea y porque podría llevar
a sospechas de que otros países como
italia y españa también van a caer en
situaciones similares pero ahorita
quedándonos en el contexto de grecia
vamos a pensar en cosas feas que van a
pasar mira va a pasar la siguiente
situación si de repente el gobierno dice
que un euro es igual a un dracma pues la
gente no es tonta o sea la gente sabe
muy bien que luego luego en cuanto
salgamos de las vacaciones bancarias el
dracma va a empezar a cambiarse en el
mercado de divisas y la gente conoce que
a partir de ahí el dracma va a perder su
valor que el dracma va a valer digamos
que va a poner un dracma va a ser igual
a pues supongamos que va a valer 60
centavos de euro o punto 6 de un euro
vale puntos 6.7 digamos que es igual a
punto siete euros vale que pasa de valer
un euro a valer punto siete euros casi
casi instantáneamente entonces cuando
suceda esto el ahorro de las personas
que tienen depósitos en dracma verdad
ahora en términos de poder adquisitivo
va a bajar en 30%
y la gente si sabe esto sabe que existe
esta posibilidad de que se convierta el
dracma y entonces qué va a suceder la
gente se forma en su banco local va a
querer retirar sus ahorros sus euros la
gente bueno antes de las vacaciones
bancarias regresar a retirar sus euros
retirar y luego que pasa bueno ya
retiran su dinero pueden depositarlo en
su cuenta de suiza o bien podrían
guardarlo en sus colchones pero esto es
una situación muy mala verdad que sucede
todo el mundo va a empezar a ir al banco
eso va a ser que más agentes vayan al
banco pero tenemos una reserva
fraccionaria entonces toda la gente va a
pedir dinero el banco nuevo a estar
preparado no va a poder darle su dinero
a las personas y eso nos lleva a un
retiro masivo retiro masivo y como ves
la cosa se va a poner fea verdad en
realidad es algo razonable si ves que el
30 por ciento de tus ahorros se va a ir
qué va a suceder esto de acá que por
cada euro sólo te voy a dar punto 7 de
euro entonces tú racionalmente vas a ir
al banco y vas a querer retirar que eso
va a empezar
suceder con todos los bancos se van a
agotar las reservas de los bancos como
grecia no tiene un banco independiente
que respalde al sistema bancario
entonces esto va a llevar así a fallas
bancarias terribles verdad fallas
bancarias
masivas especialmente esto va a llevar a
que el sistema bancario griego se caiga
esto es pues porque no hay un banco
central independiente e independiente en
el banco central europeo que quite la
leña de la hoguera como sucedería en
otros países con banco central como ves
es una situación muy dolorosa y no es
nada limpia sin embargo si no hay nada
de rescate financiero si no hay apoyo
por parte de otros países parece ser que
es la dirección en la cual grecia tiene
que ir